part they were going yeah we're
definitely going until I'm going um so
do i think the economy's going to
recover probably not 2009 um but in
terms of weather is slow down the
environment I think you will but maybe
it won't maybe what it will do is surely
make very good decisions because there's
less finance one of the things that we
have exceeded honors things like theme
capture sorry carbon capture and storage
or how do we make cold clean we think
about and talk about nuclear power
stations we talk about renewables but
actually if we're to meet our goals on
Climate fifty percent will come from
energy efficiency it's the cheapest
thing to do it's the quickest thing to
do and we can do it right now so
therefore we assured is your capital it
makes more sense so maybe we might act
quicker so maybe it was a good thing
right this is how I can no no this one
he's selling a game person that's what